biggest reason I push kids to do what
they want versus what their parents want
when you're 60 and they're 80 and you
lived your life based on what they
wanted and now you resent them it gets
real ugly real fast I would rather you
have the pain for the next five or six
years of fighting and then have one of
two things happen which I think both are
amazing number one you were right you
were right and you are in an amazing
fashion designer not an engineer and you
built a real company and your parents
are going to be very very proud or you
were wrong you suck at Fashion Design
nobody liked it but at least for
yourself you never have to live the rest
of your life asking yourself what if you
win both ways regret is scary
resentment is very scary